und bei uns ist der vorsitz der csu
landesgruppe alexander dobrindt herr
dobrindt der csu parteitag debattiert
hier heute in einem leitantrag eine
fundierung des außenpolitischen profils
der csu diese woche hat der bundestag ja
gemeinsam aus einem ampel antrag und
union für schwere waffenlieferungen
plädiert gleichzeitig sagte
ministerpräsident man muss aufpassen
dass man nicht zu früh schwere waffen
die vertrieb passt das denn zusammen ich
glaube dass niemand leicht gemacht hat
diese entscheidung und ich weiß dass es
für viele auch ganz schwer ist eine
entscheidung für schwere waffen zu
erreichen aber sie ist in der situation
in der wir uns befinden
notwendig weil die ukraine die kämpft
ums überleben und die braucht eine
unterstützung mit waffen und diesen
angriff putins standhalten zu können und
wir haben die ampel debatte in den
letzten wochen verfolgt da war sehr viel
streit da gab es keine einigkeit darüber
der gab es teilweise starke vorwürfe an
den kanzler aus der fdp aber auch aus
den grünen heraus von hütchenspielern
war die rede und von überfordert
deswegen am ester für entschlossener als
union erstens einen antrag zu stellen
damit die mehrheit diesen deutschen
bundestag gibt für eben diese
unterstützung der ukraine auch
ermöglicht wird und dann waren wir auch
bereit als sich die ampel bewegt hat
gemeinsam diesen antrag zu machen und ab
gemeinsam verantwortung für so eine jahr
schwierige entscheidung zu übernehmen
demonstration hat ja auch zugestimmt bei
im sondervermögen der bundesregierung ab
der koalition zu unterstützen
gleichzeitig das zeigt auch ihr
leitantrag beispielsweise bei der
verwendung dieser gelder aber auch beim
zum beispiel beim zwei prozent ziel der
gelder für die nato da scheint es jetzt
noch redebedarf zu geben wo sind denn da
die roten linien der union und wo du
dich an scheint jetzt schon in dieser
krisenzeit brüche auf die vielleicht
nach außen hin auch das falsche signal
sind wir befinden uns gerade in
verhandlungen von seiten der
bundesregierung ist christian lippert
der verhandlungsführung und seiten der
cdu/csu nach ich das und wir haben jetzt
in zwei treffen festgestellt dass es
noch große unterschiede in der
einschätzung geht wir wollen diese 100
milliarden für die bundeswehr
ermöglichen aber das heißt sie müssen
auch ausschließlich für unsere
streitkräfte zur verfügung stehen auf
der ampel seite gibt es da andere
vorstellungen noch für verwendung dieser
gelder das können wir nicht akzeptieren
und das zwei prozent zu dass der
bundeskanzler auch angekündigt hat dass
er sein halten ja über erfüllen will
auch das muss erreicht wird bisher hat
die bundesregierung dafür überhaupt
nichts vorgelegt und deswegen ja da ist
noch sehr viel debatte bedarf
offensichtlich noch eine ganze reihe von
behandlungen die wir brauchen der
nächste verhandlungstermin ist für
nächste woche vorgesehen und dann wird
man sehen ob man weiter kommt neben dem
thema der waffenlieferung und eben auch
der debatte wie man den bundeswehr
ertüchtigt in einem fall in dem wir
jetzt gerade sind nämlich dass nicht
genügend material hat um auch die
landesverteidigung sicherstellen zu
können ist das thema beispielsweise
immer noch kontrovers wie umgehen mit
der gas abhängigkeit gegenüber russland
auch das ein thema heute bei diesem
parteitag sie wollen mehr tun in sachen
windenergie in sachen solartechnik aber
eben auch bei grünen wasserstoff
beispielsweise ist das auch eine
kehrtwende die die csu gemacht
die weniger umgekehrt wenn er sowas geht
um das grundprinzip der souveränität wir
müssen aus den krisen auf der
vergangenen jahre heraus wieder stärker
auf eine europäische souveränität auch
deutsche souveränität drängen in einer
reihe von fragen sowohl was die energie
angelangt aber auch beispielsweise was
die medizin anbelangt wir haben ja noch
in erinnerung dass auf einmal
medikamente
nicht mehr ausreichend zur verfügung
standen als die krone krise die
lieferketten in teilen lahmgelegt hat
und wir stellen fest dass wir im bereich
der energieversorgung
und nicht auf russland verlassen können
deswegen andere wege brauchen und uns
von der russischen abhängigkeit
entfernen müssen und wir leben das wir
bei der frage auch der verteidigung
wieder stärker investieren müssen die
friedensdividende ist zerstört wurden
durch putin also europa muss
verteidigungs stärker werden dazu
braucht es einen deutlichen beitrag auch
deutschlands auch einen hohen
finanziellen beitrag der bundeskanzler
hat es gesagt eine zeitenwende in seiner
rede im februar nach dem angriff auf die
ukraine seitens russland auch ihr
leitantrag benutzt dieses wort ganz
stark gestern haben schweden und
finnland erklärt dass sie den weg weiter
beschreiten auch einer bis vielleicht
sogar einer partnerschaft in der nato
das war ja heute so ein bisschen auch
bei manfred weber hier in der rede das
thema mit blick auf den nato-gipfel im
sommer in madrid
steht europa dort vor einer wirklichen
zeitenwende einer kompletten veränderung
seiner sicherheitsarchitektur und was
bedeutet das konkret für deutschland die
zeit hätte bedeutet natürlich eine
grundlegende veränderung der
sicherheitsarchitektur
wir haben bedrohungen die wir nicht mehr
für real erachtet haben die gibt es
wieder ganz konkrete gewalt leid mord
tod in der ukraine sehen wir mit
schrecken jeden tag und deswegen habe
ich viel verständnis für länder die
bisher nicht teil der nato sind dass sie
dort mitglied werden wollen dazu wird es
auch gespräche geben müssen es gibt nach
diesen 24 februar und dem angriff
gut dienst gegen die ukraine kein zurück
mehr auf einen stand vor diesen krieg
sondern grundlegend hat sich jetzt
europa und die welt verändert ich sehe
aktuell auch überhaupt keine möglichkeit
wie nach diesen brutalen
zivilisationsbruch russland wieder als
partner an den tisch der welt sich
setzen soll von daher wir haben eine
komplette neue sicherheitspolitische
architektur und der muss man rechnung
tragen sagt der fonds etc su
landesprogramm deutschen bundestag
alexander dobrindt ist ja ganz
herzlichen dank